[Música]
fui violada en junio de 2018 por un
viejo amigo que conocía Desde hacía unos
cinco o seis años ocurrió en su casa
después de una fiesta que se hizo ahí 4
años después se hizo el juicio en el
tribunal penal de París y a los tres
días él quedó absuelto
fui violada en octubre de 2016 presente
la denuncia Gracias a mi madre a pesar
de haber tenido que esperar seis años
estaba segura de que podríamos decir
bueno se hizo justicia Pero eso no fue
lo que pasó
Honestamente lo más duro fue verlo irse
porque uno piensa hicimos todo esto para
nada
[Música]
en Francia hay cientos de historias como
las de Karina y Clara
según las más recientes cifras
publicadas por el Ministerio de Justicia
entre unos mil casos de violación solo
12 agresores terminan en la cárcel los
testimonios de las víctimas revelan las
dificultades de un periplo judicial
plagado de obstáculos en el que cada
etapa es una nueva fuente de frustración
El violador de Karim era un taxista una
noche cuando ella había salido de
trabajar el hombre la convenció de
subirse a su auto
era un taxista estaba de noche era tarde
no debía haberme subido además llora
joven y tuve que haberlo visto venir en
realidad no dejaba de pensar que tuve
que haberlo presentido que no lo vio
venir y que nadie me iba a creer si para
todo el mundo era tan evidente creo que
esa fue la sensación que más tiempo me
duró
el hombre fue identificado sus
antecedentes penales revelaron una
primera condena por agresión sexual
unos días después de la denuncia de
Karim el hombre incluso tuvo tiempo de
abusar de otra mujer antes de ser
buscado por la justicia
después de seis años de proceso penal se
determinó que el hombre había violado a
Karim pero a pesar de haber sido
condenado El violador salió libre del
tribunal por medio de una reducción de
Sentencia
[Música]
tenía una condena de cuatro años de
libertad condicional con dos años de
prisión pero con posibilidad de
reducción nos pareció que emitieron esa
sentencia a propósito para que no
pudiera pasar un solo día en la cárcel
por qué porque era un hombre con trabajo
dirigía su propia empresa y llevarlo a
la cárcel habría interferido con la
continuidad de su tratamiento
psiquiátrico que seguía Desde hacía
varios años y además porque las cárceles
están llenas
a la salida del tribunal Karim desahogó
su frustración en las redes sociales
en realidad le dieron esa pena porque
tuvo un hijo hace dos años y no se
quería romper la vida de un padre
entonces a mí me gustaría saber si violo
y después tengo un hijo Yo tampoco iría
a la cárcel o es algo que sólo pasa
cuando violan a las mujeres
esta clase de juicios mediatizados
contribuyen a debilitar la confianza en
la institución judicial
[Aplausos]
en los casos de violación muchas
víctimas no llegan hasta el final del
proceso
algunas ni siquiera se animan a
iniciarlo la primera etapa que implica
presentar una denuncia es todo un
desafío
en general una persona que ha sido
víctima de violación ha sido violada por
alguien muy o muy agresivo que le dio
órdenes de quedarse callada que la
amenazó Si hablas Te mato eso da mucho
miedo además aquí en Francia todavía hay
mucha disuasión a la hora de presentar
una denuncia porque no sabes cómo te van
a tratar Puede que no te traten bien en
febrero de 2022 una mujer fue a una
comisaría Parisina para presentar una
denuncia el policía que la volvió a
llamar al día siguiente olvidó colgar el
teléfono después de hablar con ella
cuando se trata de violaciones los
estereotipos son difíciles de superar
tenemos un caso en el que una mujer
había sido violada por un hombre que
había conocido por internet y el policía
le había dicho señora un encuentro con
alguien que conoció por internet en la
casa del agresor hay que desconfiar no
no se puede hablar realmente de
violación la mujer se fue sin presentar
una denuncia
en Francia solo una de cada 10 mujeres
Víctimas de violación Presenta una
denuncia
en esta comisaría Se tomaron medidas a
la altura del problema
en la entrada la confidencialidad
todavía es limitada porque hay que
identificarse como víctima de violencia
sexual sentada al lado de un desconocido
que ha venido a denunciar el robo de su
billetera
pero aquí la principal Consigna es la
comprensión las víctimas son recibidas
por un investigador especializado un
psicólogo y un asistente social tienen
incluso una habitación especial para las
mujeres que llegan en situación de
emergencia extrema
es un espacio pequeño pero totalmente
equipado con baño ducha lavamanos y lo
necesario para pasar la noche con una
cama y una cobija también hay una
segunda cama en caso de que la víctima
venga con un niño para que puedan pasar
la noche aquí
hemos visto la diferencia que a veces
puede haber entre los relatos y la
cantidad de denuncias presentadas y la
cantidad de investigaciones Entonces nos
pareció que era indispensable mejorar
Para inspirar confianza para probar que
estamos 100% a su disposición que no
volveremos a pasar nada por alto
sistemáticamente de inmediato se
notifica a la fiscalía para que la
investigación tenga una orientación
desde el comienzo
a partir de ese momento las denuncias
quedan en manos del fiscal pero para las
víctimas es una especie de lotería que
constituye la segunda etapa de su
periplo judicial eriko es el fiscal
general del tribunal de apelación de
poitié desde hace 30 años trabaja en la
fiscalía sabe que la percepción de los
jueces puede resultar determinante en el
seguimiento de los casos en Francia el
70% de las denuncias que se reciben se
clasifican sin darles seguimiento para
evitar este problema El fiscal aboga por
una formación especial para los jueces
lo cual implica primero de todo repasar
la legislación
hace cuando se recibe una denuncia o se
comprueba un hecho se debe analizar si
se cumplen todas las condiciones de esa
infracción hubo efectivamente
penetración de tipo sexual y además hay
que saber si esa penetración sexual se
cometió bajo coacción bajo sorpresa bajo
violencia o bajo amenaza
Cómo se debe analizar la ley para
comprobar si es aplicable o no a los
hechos que se nos presentan
la infracción significa recolectar
pruebas otro gran obstáculo las víctimas
son remitidas a unidades clínico
forenses como esta el único organismo
autorizado para elaborar los informes
médicos admisibles en un tribunal penal
pero en la mayoría de los casos el
examen no revela ningún signo visible de
la violación
cuando la víctima se da cuenta de que la
persona la está sujetando con demasiada
fuerza o de que está tratando de
estrangularla para evitar que grite y
que corre el riesgo de ahogarse no solo
tiene miedo de que la violen sino
también de que la maten entonces piensa
Bueno voy a dejarme entre comillas
porque no quiero morir y por eso a veces
no encontramos lesiones y agresión o de
defensa no las hay o son muy mínimas
ante la cantidad de demandas y la falta
de médicos forenses a veces es necesario
esperar hasta 15 días para obtener una
cita
tiempo suficiente para que desa en los
hematomas y otros Rastros de ADN
porque hay que tener una cita hablando
de emergencias legales es un poco
contradictorio pero es para evitar que
lleguen 10 personas a la vez y también
porque se necesita tener tiempo
suficiente para dedicarle a cada persona
no solo hay que hacer un examen físico
también hay que evaluar el impacto
psicológico y eso a menudo toma más
tiempo la recolección de pruebas parece
una carrera contrarreloj pero a veces se
necesitan años para que una víctima tome
conciencia de la violación y se decida a
presentar una denuncia
no siempre hay pruebas materiales porque
a veces las víctimas denuncian los
hechos mucho tiempo después y eso
Efectivamente es algo muy común Pero en
esos casos se buscan otras pruebas es el
trabajo de los investigadores y de la
institución judicial Buscar otras
pruebas
Buscar otras pruebas implica un largo
ciclo de peritaje y peritaje de
comprobación la vida de las víctimas es
examinada con lupa todas las personas de
su círculo cercano son interrogadas y la
investigación judicial puede resultar
particularmente extenuante y larga en
promedio el proceso tarda seis años para
una víctima adulta y cerca de diez para
una víctima menor de edad los elementos
presentados en los tribunales penales
delante de jueces Escogidos al azar
pueden ser devastadores tanto para los
acusados como para las víctimas y
afectar los veredictos los jueces lo
saben para garantizar la condena de los
agresores a veces se propone una
alternativa que roza el límite de la
correccionalizar los hechos los acusados
ya no son juzgados por violación sino
por agresión sexual
[Música]
mi abogada me lo dijo como si la
correccionalización fuera una etapa más
del proceso le Proponen como una especie
de compromiso para las víctimas diciendo
mire si no quiere esperar durante años y
años y potencialmente quedar
decepcionada le proponemos esta solución
yo no quería no había sido una agresión
sexual Entonces no quería que fuera
juzgado como una agresión sexual
Clara también rechazó esa alternativa
estaba convencida de tener todas las
pruebas necesarias para ver a su agresor
tras las rejas el informe médico
elaborado al día siguiente de la
agresión registraba lesiones vaginales y
anales compatibles con las declaraciones
de Clara pero cuatro años después
durante el juicio la defensa obtuvo un
testimonio el de la exnovia del agresor
presentado por el agente de la policía
judicial respecto a sus relaciones
sexuales él no insi stía y era muy
respetuoso ella precisó que él tenía un
pene enorme y que ni siquiera le servían
los preservativos xxl el alegato se
presentó para justificar la causa de las
lesiones ginecológicas de Clara la
defensa logró sembrar la duda y
finalmente el acusado fue absuelto
yo estoy condenado de por vida siempre
seré la mujer a la que no tomaron en
serio a pesar de haberlo hecho todo bien
me examinaron me encontraron pruebas les
di todos los detalles que pude les abrí
mi vida hice todo lo que había que hacer
tras la emisión del veredicto Clara
trató de acabar con su vida saltando del
balcón del Palacio de justicia
la justicia y las asociaciones piden más
recursos para poder mejorar sus
servicios y desarrollar programas de
formación el objetivo es de construir
los estereotipos sobre la violación que
con mucha frecuencia interfieren en los
trámites y los veredictos en nueve de
cada 10 casos la violación no ocurre en
un callejón sombrío sino en el silencio
del hogar a Puerta cerrada El violador
es su esposo su amigo su colega su ex
pareja y a menudo los violadores no son
conscientes de ser violadores
[Música]
según el alto consejo de igualdad de
género una de cada tres mujeres en
Francia Afirma haber sido víctima de una
agresión sexual o de una violación